c'est bon et c'est réjouissant a dit le
porte-parole à Moscou à propos de des
jeunes qui scandaient gorbachchov les
divergences entre le régime est allemand
et ses intellectuels sa jeunesse révélé
lors de ses concerts rock sont très
profondes pour Antenne 2 isabelle bchler
a enquêté dans ses milieu de la
contestation à Berlin
est une star vient leur rendre visite
les Berlinois de l'Ouest de l'Est n'en
cro pas leurs yeux c'est M gorb
ê
l'espoir pour nous gorbachov c'est
l'espoir mais j'espère qu'il
en l'un de ceux qui s'inquièteent
ericheker semblait pourtant n'avoir
aucune réticence voilà quelques semaines
il faut dire que la position estalemande
est délicate l'économie se porte bien
mieux que celle de l'URSS et donc
officiellement la RDA n'a rien à
apprendre du grand frère soviétique mais
quand il s'agit de démocratisation de
transparence le gouvernement trouve bien
trop hardi les propositions
soviétiques on parle beaucoup du
programme de gorbachchov on en discute
je sens que pour la première fois une
grande partie de la population évoque
des sujets qui étaient confiné dans une
sorte de tabou discussion sur le système
électoral sur l'autogestion dans les
entreprises et cetera Noart
Tabone habenmlich eine Diskussion über
das wahlsystem über eine
selbstverwaltung in den betrieben und
ähnliche probleme le fait que notre
gouvernement estime que ces changements
ne sont pas nécessaires en RDA met en
évidence l'énorme fossé entre
leouvernement et la
population ce pouvoir qui semble si loin
des préoccupations des citoyens doit
pourtant compter avec la télévision West
allemande fini la censure absolue en RDA
on fabrique en série des téléviseurs B
standard les intellectuels sont
sceptiques par rapport à une révolution
qui viendrait d'en haut et qui ne serait
le fait que de quelques individus car la
démocratie ça doit venir d'en
bas mais on observe avec intérêt et même
un véritable espoir tout ce qui se
passe alors bon ben nous verrons ce qui
en sortiront l'exemple soviétique peut
valoir en matière de
je serais ravi qu'on puisse ouvrir des
maisons d'édition
indépendantes quand au théâtre il serait
bon qu'on autorise des troupes à
travailler libr comme c'est le
casuellement dernier signe de
libéralisation peut-être dû à un effet
gorbach les libération de prisonniers
d'opinion 500 depuis janvier et puis il
y a la place de l'église qui peut
fonctionner sans les éternelles
autorisations du pouvoir politique
d'ailleurs un groupe de pasteurs a pris
la liberté d'envoyer un télégramme de
soutien à
gorbachov nous lui avons écrit que nous
nous réjouissions de ces initiatives
politiques sur le désarmement que nous
nous réjouissions de la libération de
sakarof et que nous espérions pour
l'année 87 qu'il Prenn encore d'autres
mesures
humanitaires reste à trouver une VO
autonome les intellectuels de
l'opposition s'y
emploi ce que je souhaite est une autre
forme de vie pas la vie de l'Ouest qu'on
essaie de singer ici en RDA mais à un
moyen terme entre l'Est et
l'Ouest